[Music]
one of the most interesting patterns in
East Asian history which is quite
different from the European matter is
that when China's strong and big there's
a lot less fighting and when China falls
apart then there's some vicious fighting
as everybody jockeys for position so
whether we go back to the transition of
the Ming Dynasty in the 17th century or
we get to the collapse of the ching
dynasty in the 20th century when china
is weak there's a lot of fighting when
china is strong in many ways countries
get along better
well the rise of china in the last 20
years in many ways has been accompanied
with increasing stability around the
region if you go back 40 years ago to
1978 that's the beginning of china's
economic reforms and it's phenomenal
economic growth before then china was a
poor country caught in the throes of a
Cultural Revolution where maybe a
million Chinese died they were fomenting
revolution and supporting revolutionary
groups around the region since that time
over the last 40 years China's economy
has exploded 400 million Chinese have
gone out of poverty it looks nothing
like it was before so China's domestic
situation is far more stable than before
at the same time what's happening to
trade in the region everybody's now
trading with China countries may not
like what China's doing politically but
they don't fear invasion Vietnam isn't
worried about invasion Korea's net worry
about invasion but what do they do they
are trying to rapidly expand their
economic links with China so the region
now is getting knit together in ways
that it used to look like before and so
there's more interaction among these
countries not less one of the things
that's not that surprising but also
really important is how little we in the
West we in the United States know about
East Asian history almost all of our
theories and
almost all of the history we learned
whether it's on high school or college
or even graduate school is about Europe
and that's fine sure I mean that's I
understand why it is but the fact is
there's a lot of East Asian history that
doesn't look anything like European
history and if we want to understand
that reason it might help to actually
understand East Asian history in many
ways as Eurocentric focus really does
put us at a disadvantage in making
policy towards Asia because in some ways
we are talking ourselves into conflicts
that I don't think necessarily have to
exist and the perfect example is this
whole Thucydides trap if you go to DC
right now or if you read almost any
foreign Pauline policy magazine or even
scholarly journals that talk about East
Asia it is essentially a conventional
wisdom now essentially I would say
scholars and policymakers from the left
and from the right
almost everybody takes for granted in
the United States that China's rise can
be a threat that we better be prepared
to contain that there's going to be some
kind of a titanic struggle but most of
this is based not on what China is doing
but is based on a belief that it must
inevitably happen so just wait it may
not be happening now but it's going to
happen in the future
so even when for example I'll do a talk
and I'll show evidence over the last 25
years that in many ways East Asia is
more stable and defense spending is not
as big as people think I met with a wall
of skepticism where people like no no no
you don't understand
just wait it's gonna happen in the
future it's not based on any knowledge
it's not based on any evidence it's
based on a belief about the world but
that belief about the world isn't formed
from Europe and not East Asia and so
having real knowledge about the informal
rules and lessons and and places to
avoid is incredibly important and one
thing you know that happens with US
businesses this goes back to decades is
that often American businesses will
choose advisors you need a guide you
absolutely need it in in a guide from
the inside but I've seen this happen
over and over again where an American
business
a French consulting company helped them
do something in Europe so they feel
comfortable with a French company and
they will choose that company to help
them go to China and it never made any
sense to me right they choose that
because that's who they know or you know
an American adviser who says well I
helped you get into Costa Rica I can
help you go to China there's only one
way to do it which is to put the time in
do your due diligence and find a guide
on the inside oh I did a project once
for a foreign company and they came to
me after they had had it this is in
Korea right I helped a company go to
Korea set up business there and they
only came to me after they had hired a
Singaporean company consulting company
to help them go to Korea and I remember
we talked it was like why would you hire
Singapore they're not Korean you know
and yet companies often skimp on that
they skimp on the most important things
which are these local domestic knowledge
that can help you really understand
don't talk to that guy in that guy
because they both hate each other kind
of kind of issues that is only available
when you have the deep local knowledge
I know these are generic points and they
seem obvious but you'd be surprised how
many companies just simply barge ahead
without actually spending enough time
and finding the right the right local
fixers you can see this with the ways in
which we have advisors to the US
government the actual number of people
who have deep knowledge of the region
are easily outnumbered by those who have
technical knowledge or nuclear-weapons
knowledge or arms-control knowledge or
regular generic knowledge of
international relations I just don't
think we're even that aware of much less
supportive of having people who actually
know the region I don't have one or two
and yet the number of people who expound
on this is what China is doing who have
no idea what China looks like but our IR
scholars you know IR theorists or arms
control theorists far outnumber those
who are actually China experts so or
East Asia experts or Vietnam exports and
so in many ways I would actually think
this is this is a
important thing that we need to start to
rectify both in scholarship and then in
affecting policy is we need better area
studies knowledge
[Music]